moi j'ai l'impression que françois
hollande c'est déjà le passé j'ai on a
déjà l'impression qu' il ne gouverne
plus pays que quand il parle au bout
d'une minute et demie vous arrêtez de
l'écouter c'est terrible parce que c'est
le président de la république que il a
il ne prend plus en main les grandes
décisions qu'il devait prendre il a
renoncé aux grandes réformes sur
lesquelles il s'était engagé
donc pour moi fonctionnant c'est déjà le
passé c'est déjà le passé c'est un mort
vivant comme l'a dit nous y en a un
non non non non j'aime pas je veux pas
la mer à cette occasion là je pense
qu'il est temps qu'ils prennent de très
grandes vacances qui selon lui seront
certainement très mérité vous considérez
que sa nouvelle candidature serait une
heure et fils qui veut un enregistreur
du parti socialiste avait la politique
qu'il a menée la mnef vassaux des bulles
à mener avec montebourg avec tous les
autres et de la mnef macron qui règle
juste le maquereau aujourd'hui on a
appris qu'il pourrait très vite être
candidat en tout cas avant le 10
décembre
c'est pas mon logiciel politique mais je
trouve que ce serait un magnifique
adversaires au moins il renouvelle le
paysage politique après c'est un libéral
qui s'assume
je préfère le libéralisme assumé d'un
macron ma libre alice trait à la
française un trait medef quand même on a
honte a pas aux rentes du medef donc on
tape au rang du nucléaire on tape on
rentre de la finance on t'a pas aux
rentes du bon donc je regrette qu'il ait
qui voit là mais c'est un libéral qui
s'assume hollande et valls se prétendent
des socialistes mais qu'ils font quand
même plutôt une politique libérale qui
s'assume pas je préfère quelqu'un qui
s'assume qui est nouveau dans le paysage
politique et ce sera encore une fois un
adversaire je crois de talent mais en
tous les cas c'est lui qui aurait pris
le moins de coups de votre part dans
cette émission passe alors qu'est-ce que
vous avez tapé sur la gomme et non mais
je te ggg vous savez je suis dans une
énorme frustration je suis dans une
énorme frustration on a un pays qui est
au bord de la rupture et on a un pays
qui pourrait basculer si vite parce que
l'agriculture qui fait du bien elle
existe les citoyens qui veulent protéger
leur santé ils sont déjà sensibilisés
les choix industriels station qui créent
de l'emploi frustre à milan c'est quoi
mais parce que ce pays ne ne se met pas
en vous
autour de ces solutions ne se met pas
non parce que sur regard pour un coût
macron sur l'écologie les nus ah oui
mais il est nul avec mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que il ya tellement de force
vitale dans ce pays qui font des choses
magnifiques
si c'était à eux qu'ont laissé l'espace
et non pas ceux qui nous empêchent
d'avancer
ceux qui sont les laits des artisans du
conservatisme du corporatisme de la
rente et du blocage des institutions ce
qu'empêche notre pays mais il il est là
a basculé potentiellement dans une
économie qui avance et dans une société
qui retrouve la con